one of the first things I check when I'm
reading a business book or a great
article or YouTube that a friend shared
with me is I want to know if that author
that speaker or that writer of that
article did they ever run a real
business did they ever run a real
startup did they ever build this startup
that became a multi-million dollar
company that eventually was acquired
about or you know so four billion
dollars or went public I want to know
that because I want to know if that's a
person that was in the trenches that did
it and went through it and had the
victory or it was somebody who ran a
startup didn't work they quit and they
became an author or consultant I want to
know that I want to talk to people and
learn from people who are in the
trenches building it this is why there's
only a few people that I read a book
I've really studied their counsel based
on what they personally went through so
with that being said micromanaging most
of us cannot stand a word micromanage if
anybody's a new entrepreneur or somebody
in leadership position you'll hear
somebody say don't ever micromanage
don't ever do this and we'll I kids oh
my god my mom my dad said don't ever do
this so we don't ever do it and we think
it's such a terrible well we don't look
into it I want to explain it to in a way
maybe you haven't thought about it
before in the past so hopefully it
untangled some of the confusion you have
in your mind and then we can go from
there first of all let's define what the
word micromanage means it means to
control every part however small to
control every part however small I
remember was about a year and a half ago
I was in an inky vent with Mark Cuban
and one of the questions was asked is if
you run so many companies and you have
so many different seals a shark tank how
do you deal with these CEOs he said I
micromanage the CEOs and the leaders
until I trust them
key word this is a three billion dollar
guy not just an author this is a three
billion dollar guy who builds businesses
who's built businesses and owns
businesses and coaches CEO saying I
micromanage and leaders and CEOs of
companies until I trust them then I let
them go right so two ways you got to
look at micromanaging what is people the
other one is procedure what is people
want is procedure and let me explain to
you in a way that maybe you look at it
differently so
the word micromanage has negative
connotations we already identified that
no problem so but there's a lot of
people that also say the word cult has
negative connotations but then we're
very comfortable to use the word culture
and we don't realize the first four
letters of culture is cold oh my gosh
if we don't like cold we should never
use the word culture because Apple is a
cult because they have a strong culture
Walmart is a cult because have a strong
culture you know Microsoft is a common
because have a strong culture you know
Zappos cut we go back to no no no I
can't use this for but I'm very
comfortable using this word now once we
break it down then people say oh I never
thought about it this way that's what it
is now of course there's a lot of
negative cults that we're talking a
business there's a lot of great cults in
there for businesses so micromanaging
there's really two places your
micromanage one of them has a very short
lifespan
the other one has a longer lifespan in
raising a family if you don't
necessarily watch what your kids are
doing and you kind of let them loose
you're leaving a lot of it to chance if
you just allow your kids and so you know
what I'm very comfortable my kids being
out there from from a young age you can
go outside and do whatever they want to
do I'm free I'm free spirited you know
it's kind of how I feel like they can go
whatever they want to do very few
parents feel that way unless they're
forced to do that because their living
conditions but for the most part were
like no he's got to go to school and
then we would like him to do this I'd
like to put him in some sports I think
it's good to learn discipline when he
goes to school and you got to wake up
and you got to make your bed and you got
to do this how come you didn't do this
did you do their homework let's go out
there and do this are you learning how
to write how to read what if we don't do
that then we don't build a leader right
so think about if you don't do that now
if it's always like did you do this did
you do that the approach is a problem so
the reason why we have a challenge will
micromanage because the person that was
leading you was so much about this that
it just completely eventually frustrated
you I generally my style the way I hire
people as at the moment I trust them
very similar to mark I let them go and I
just monitor once a month or if I have
to inspect I do that but there's one
thing I micromanage all the time all the
time
that's procedures okay there is never a
lifespan
where you'll never micromanage
procedures again this very short
lifespan very short lifespan you'll do
that then from there you're just leading
them
you may micromanage a little bit for
them to learn them you're just leading
them guiding them mentoring them
encouraging them you're doing that
because people are people and they gotta
have Canadore own space to do their
thing so their creativity works if
you're too much over that it doesn't
happen but procedures don't have
feelings they have feelings they have
emotions they need to be free they want
to spread their wings and fly sometimes
they want to kind of have their own
freedom yes you got to give that to
people because they are humans they they
bleed they have emotions they have heart
procedures don't have emotions don't
have heart you over micromanage this you
micromanage this like you have no idea
so what do I mean by procedures go
through your sales flow so what is your
sales Pro what is step number one of
your sales flow what is number two of
yourself throw three four or five you
need to go through this and find out
where the leak is and fix that you need
to go through the flow of a customer
service when somebody calls in they
first get answered and so what is this
script so let me go through the code so
I call front desk and if somebody calls
what is the script if the front desk
says how can I help you
you don't say how can I help you how may
I help you you need to introduce
yourself hi this is Mary how may I help
you
oh this is this oh great great thank you
for calling me I please place you on my
ask who's calling this is John :
John Matt gets your telephone number in
case we get disconnected no problem that
that uh may I please place you on hold
yes thank you so much women sir okay let
me get a book No so that's procedure I
checked that we got to fix that script
here's a script I'll put it there change
the script this is how we intro next
great okay so how's the flow when
somebody comes into my office how are
they greeted so somebody walks it oh hi
how are you who are you here to see John
probably perfect could you please sign
any and grab a seat excellent thank you
so much would you like something to
drink yes would you like water tea or
coffee water you go get them water and
bring them back procedure okay once a
piece of business comes into your
business then what do you do what first
gets faxed in then it gets scanned in
then it gets uploaded well why do we
have fax we've already graduated fax so
we need to get rid of facts can we just
make an upload so if it gets uploaded
and it's coming to me
then who touches it next well the next
person touches is the one they touch it
what do they do then they put the
reported over here on when they report
it can we make this
not manual instead it's automatic so
it's happening immediately yeah we don't
have it right now but what do we need to
do to make this I want to make the
procedure instead of taking seven hours
to take in two and a half hours to take
in forty-three minutes to take in 22
minutes to take in six minutes to take
in 52 seconds for 38 seconds the more
you micromanage that procedure you
eventually make it faster you
micromanage the step step number one we
do this step number two we do this step
number three then there is a
duplicatable replicatable step system in
place for every procedure you have to
get it done if you sit and micromanage
this now I'll hear some entrepreneurs
I'll talk to and they'll say things like
this look I'm more divisionary I don't
deal with the minutia it is the dumbest
thing I hear entrepreneurs say because
they think this visionary is going to
build a billion dollar company or a
million dollar company by purely being
this visionary they're so proud to be
visionary listen if you're not too
careful micromanaging your procedures
this visionary will envision themselves
very quickly into being an unemployed
visionary and to having a job very
simple as that this visionary needs to
buckle down and forget about the fact
that your visionary the only time you're
a true visionary or CEO is when other
people call you visionary and a CEO
other people will identify you as that
till then you need to get your system
flow in place you need to get your
business flow in place you need to get
your procedures in place you need to be
looking at this over and over and over
and over and over again and figure out
ways how to speed it up figure out ways
how to make it more faster more
efficient more clear this is what you
ought to micromanage over and over and
over and over again and yes this is
boring
this ain't exciting this is not a
motivational speech to tell you never
ever micromanage anything because it's
terrible that's no that's our
motivational speakers when you get dirty
and you're running a business and it's
morning till night and you have to make
cash flow and you have to make numbers
and investors give you a call and you're
getting on conference calls and you have
to invest to you know investor relations
and staff and employees and payroll and
all this other stuff hiring and firing
and you know suffers you're buying four
million
for half a million bucks you start
realizing this is real business there
are people involved and those that are
really on it end up building a business
that lasts this is why only 5% of
entrepreneurs make it 5% of
entrepreneurs make it because they don't
sit there and go really and deep into
the details of things that it takes to
build a business up and once you do you
realize there's a formula for so the
message today is very simple when you
get off this video I want you to watch
another video I did a few months ago
it's called how to scale your business
can we put a picture of how to scale
your business so they know what it looks
like but we'll make sure we put a link
on the bottom here matter of fact let's
put a link right here and add an
annotation - can we put a ring put a
ringtone as I can hear the ring how you
go I like that ringtone let's put a link
here click on this it'll take you to how
to scale your business if you watch this
video because somebody's taking it and
stolen and put on on their website
that's no problem go on Patrick baby
calm also here Patrick baby calm and
under you'll find a video how to scale
your business watch that video because
that video tells you how to take your
procedures and scale your business but
at this point I want you to grab a pen
and paper and write all the procedures
of your business that you have and ask
yourself how can I speed up the process
of this procedure and on a daily basis
listen minimum weekly but if you can do
it on a daily basis
study your procedures and make them
tighter and eventually your procedures
will make you tenfold hundredfold a
thousandfold of results that you ever
fathomed or thought about because this
makes the business predictable anyways
that's my message to you based on the
question that was asked on Facebook by
one of our fans which was a great
question but if you haven't subscribed
to this channel do so as well if you got
any questions comment on the bottom
thanks for watching
take care
you